the Vatican's former ambassador to the
United States is publicly accusing Pope
Francis of covering up for an abusive
Cardinal and he's calling on the Pope to
resign
we will analyze what this means for the
future of the Catholic Church then Eric
Edgar stops by to discuss his new book
fraud how the left plans to steal the
next election then the mainstream media
which savaged John McCain in 2008 when
it actually mattered are now rolling out
the panegyrics after the Senators death
we'll explain why finally an update on
the socialist gift that keeps on giving
Alexandria Ocasio Cortez I'm Michael
Knowles and this is the Michael Nolt
show
[Music]
so much to get to today you know
sometimes I actually try to limit my
flagrant potpourri and pape ISM to the
mailbag because I get a lot of questions
about it so I don't want it to be the
whole show and then the Catholic Church
becomes the biggest news story in the
entire world so this is one area where I
think my potpourri will really serve
because the mainstream media are totally
getting this wrong this is way way
bigger even than they are reporting
before we get to all of that we have got
to thank our wonderful sponsor ring ring
is very very cool it will make you safer
it will make you look cooler it will
make your friends respect you more it is
great it is the future they make this
video doorbell that connects to your
phone so they have totally changed the
game of home security
there used to be the neighborhood watch
which was inefficient and ineffective
now you got ring you can see the guy
who's coming up you can talk to way see
it on your phone whether you're on a
beach in Boca or you're in your house or
apartment it's really I'll just set this
up because they send me these clips and
they're amazing to watch so this guy
runs away here but it's only because he
had a ring is probably on drugs or some
whacked out guy let's just play the clip
hello hey leave my house I'm calling the
police
okay what you need to do here's my house
stop now or I'm calling the police
why would you tell me that because
you're trying to push my door in leave
now what's in there I'm calling the
police
okay I am the police handed to him for
the amount of drugs that that guy is
certainly on it was pretty quick
thinking like I am the police you don't
look like the police ring is
unbelievable you can see what's going on
at your front door you can really stop
crime that's a very empowering it'll
help you protect your family and also
you'll you can just track who's coming
to your house delivery guys it gets
uploaded to the cloud you know even if
someone even if the burglar steals your
ring doorbell you'll have all of that
video on the cloud you can share it
instantly to neighbors
get it this is the future and it's
pretty inexpensive thieves just can't
hide with a ring save up to $150 on a
ring of security kit at ring.com slash
Knowles kano wles don't say I never did
nothing for you these things are already
very very low priced and you'll save 150
bucks on a ring of security cap ring
comm slash Noel's hundred fifty bucks
off when you go to ring calm / Knowles
Cantor wles okay let's I just want to
break this down for you this Vatican
Catholic Church scandal and we'll see
there are going to be new things that
come out but I want to give you the
basic outlook because the mainstream
media are lying about this first of all
there are very few things that are
unprecedented in the history of the
Catholic Church you know there have been
multiple Empires Pope's being kidnapped
by tyrants and invaders and this and
then this is unprecedented a top Vatican
official is accusing the Pope of
covering up for an abusive priests and
he's calling on that pope to resign this
is utterly unprecedented and this poses
serious questions not only for Francis's
pontificate but for the state of Western
Christianity and Western civilization I
this the significance of this letter
that came out from the Vatican's former
representative to Washington at 11 page
letter outlining all of this it cannot
be overstated how significant this is so
let's get through it very quickly
because then we got to talk about
election fraud and how the left is gonna
steal the next election the the Cardinal
to write this testimony is the former
nun CEO to Washington to the Vatican's
representative to the United States for
some context the United States and
Germany basically funds the Catholic
Church and so this is the Vatican's rep
to the United States that that's what
the word nuncio means some people are
pronouncing at Nunzio
Nunzio is the name of my Italian uncle
who lives in the Bronx nun Co is the the
representative to the United States his
name is Carlo Maria Vigano
in his 11 page testimony he outlines
abuse and he names names specifically we
saw a guy named Cardinal McCarrick step
down he was the first guy to step down
from the College of Cardinals
in almost a hundred years he stepped
down just a couple of weeks ago amid
allegations of abusing not only minors
but a lot of seminarians and a lot of
priests I've talked to priests friends
about this I've talked to sources about
this they say this was widely known not
that he was abusing kids but that he was
abusing seminarians and priests and was
allowed to persist by bishops who were
covering it up including his successors
including his pals in the Catholic
clergy including Cardinal Wuerl by the
way so this is from this testimony which
outlines all of the abuse quote Cardinal
Wuerl well aware of the continuous
abuses committed by Cardinal McCarrick
and the sanctions imposed imposed on him
by Pope Benedict transgressing the
Pope's order also allowed him to reside
at a Seminary in Washington DC in doing
so he put other seminarians at risk so
one thing that's being really
misrepresented here in the mainstream
media
I think the Washington Post did this is
they said that the according to this
testimony both Pope Benedict and Pope
Francis both of them knew about the
abuse of Cardinal McCarrick and that's
technically true what what is left out
here the lie of omission is that Pope
Benedict punished Cardinal McCarrick he
sent this bad abusive Cardinal who
abused a lot of priests and and some
minors he sent him to into seclusion he
you know put Benedict to defrocked a
number of abusive priests pelea sized
them took them out of the clergy and he
said mckarrick has did not appear in
public he can't live in the seminaries
he needs to be punished well these
things are being investigated when Pope
Francis came to power he reinstated
mckarrick he gave him all of his old
privileges back and the Cardinal who
replaced him allowed him to live at the
seminaries where he had been abusing
priests before this is high corruption
rank corruption if this was reported
also directly to Francis so the author
of this testimony is saying I spoke to
Francis directly I know that Francis
knows about this I told it to him with
my own lips so but one example here is
this guy
vegan oh it was speaking to Francis and
Pope Francis apparently asked him what
do you know about Cardinal
carick vegan Oh said there's a dossier
this thick on Cardinal McCarrick
outlining his abuse of priests and
seminarians again not not little boys
but of other people in the clergy this
big and you should know about that and
when he left he later found out
according to this testimony that Pope
Francis knew mckarrick had spoken
previously to McCarrick and perhaps was
just trying to suss out what vegan Oh
thought about mckarrick in order to
figure out who to promote and who to
demote but we do know that Francis ripp
empowered McCarrick he let him go to
China as a representative of the Vatican
he let him go all over lemon seminaries
and basically have free rein in the
exact opposite of what Pope Benedict
allowed him to do so the the issue here
is that Pope Francis won't respond at
the end of this papal of this testimony
from Cardinal vegan oh he says the Pope
should resign the Pope knew the Pope
should resign and this is not some power
play here because the Cardinal who wrote
this is retired it's not he doesn't have
anything personally to gain from this
and he's been a top-level official for a
long time including under Pope Francis
and he just is a credible guy according
to all of the other sources so what does
Francis say to this nothing nothing he
was asked by the press what he's going
to say and respond to these calls for
resignation unprecedented in the history
of the church and Francis responds quote
I read that statement this morning I
read it and I will say sincerely and
that I must say this to you and all of
you who are interested read the document
carefully and judge it for yourselves I
will not say one word on this I think
the statement speaks for itself and you
have sufficient journalistic capacity to
reach your own conclusions are you
kidding me
or are you kidding me this is utterly
unacceptable these are serious
allegations but made by a very serious
person and he says posh pish posh I
don't owe you an explanation no thanks
and this is very much in keeping with
the Francis pontificate he has done this
time and again the theological
undercurrent which is not really being
reported on is that as Pope Francis has
said things that seem to be in direct
contradiction to 2,000 years of church
doctrine there have been there were four
including the considered conservative
Cardinal Cardinal Raymond Burke who sent
what are called a Dubya to Pope Francis
five questions about statements he's
made to clarify what he's saying and
make sure that he's not promoting heresy
again a serious document given
respectfully hand-delivered to the papal
residence Francis said I'm not going to
respond wouldn't respond to this day
does not respond in fact that those
Dubya were only published two months
after Francis refused to admit that he
received them just know he just will not
answer his critics this is very much in
keeping and another aspect of the
Francis pontificate is he has seemed to
dismiss if not denigrate younger
Catholics who are more serious about
orthodoxy and more serious about
traditional liturgies than he is he's
denigrated them he says they're too
rigid oh don't be too rigid why are you
young people too rigid just dismissing
and dismissing and dismissing them you
know one wonders if Pope Francis will
take his own advice here because he's
called for transparency constantly we
need transparency we need the end of
clericalism he's always blaming this
abuse on clericalism well clericalism
referring to all of these corrupt
bishops and taking their their offices
you know and making idols of their
offices and abusing their offices one
wonders if he'll take this seriously -
do we need transparency do we do we need
are we going to have transparency from
Pope Francis are we going to have an end
to clericalism I don't know more on that
in a second a lot of other people are
implicated in this a lot of other
Americans are implicated in this
testimony one of whom is Cardinal cubish
Cardinal cubish is Cardinal in Chicago
he was he was appointed by mckarrick and
world - other guys who have been
seriously corrupted who we know have
been corrupted he was appointed
apparently because of their influence
another little bit for those of you who
are not in the Catholic no Cardinal
cubish is referred to in some quarters
as Cardinal cupcake by by more
conservative I certainly I wouldn't use
that phrase it's so uncharitable but
they do call him Cardinal cupcake and so
anyway Cardinal cubish then responds to
these
allegations against him he said quote
the former nun CEO is confused about the
sequence of events this is astonishing
Pope Francis has made it clear he wants
pastoral bishops and I work each day to
live up to that expectation in
collaboration bla bla bla bla bla he
just refused to do it and he says the
annunzio is confused the new NCO doesn't
seem to be confused if anybody is
confused its Cardinal cubish who is time
and time again confused Catholic
doctrine and confused people by playing
politics by leaning toward left ISM and
by playing the press he you know he
called for absolute clarity these are
the words of Cardinal cubish absolute
clarity that he would ban guns from
churches and parishes
well he's Archbishop but then he's a
little less clear on other aspects when
he was the Bishop of Rapid City he was
less clear on abortion he said well you
know we have to consider both sides and
when there was an anti-abortion bill up
to the legislature well we have to I
don't know it's not that clear you know
bla bla bla know it that are you kidding
me that's a very very clear when he was
the when he was the Bishop of Spokane he
clearly prohibited the traditional
liturgy traditional liturgical books he
also was very clear when he said that
priests and seminarians shouldn't
protest against Planned Parenthood oh
he's very clear about that but now he he
seems very confused about things that
matter
he seems very confused he's is unclear
about same-sex marriage he so well you
know do to do to do very very unclear I
hope we get a little clarity because
these people who seem to call for
clarity all all the way up the Vatican
hierarchy then seem to be very unclear
when the light shines on them they seem
to be a little unclear on doctrine too
so I I hope this is a moment this has
been a very challenging pontificate for
the church because there have been so
many confusing statements so many
statements that seem to contradict
Catholic doctrine and apparently now so
many cover-ups of abuse so many
cover-ups if you have two pontificates
you have Pope Benedict responding to an
abusive priests by punishing him well
while he's being investigated and you
have a nut in the next Pope essentially
promoting him those are two very
different views and to stand there and
say we need more transparency more or
less clericalism
or honesty while you're covering that up
raises serious serious questions of
integrity so the question is what to do
because we've got to get to our
interview but I know people are gonna be
wondering not just Catholics but
Christians generally what do we do about
this
the first answer is don't flee the
church the church has been through a lot
of bad things before a lot of speaking
even to the Protestant denominations
they've been through a lot of scandals
before the answer isn't to leave the
church
you know whenever there's a big issue in
politics or in the church
I've noticed this week after week very
often the reading from Scripture that
week speaks directly to it call it
Providence call it coincidence what have
you this week on Sunday it was a reading
from I think it's John 6 which is right
after the Bread of Life sermon Christ
says I'm the bread of life this is a
hard saying you have to eat my flesh and
drink my blood and he says to the
disciples people leave him it's too it's
too hard for them to hear this and he
says will you leave too and Peter
responds and says to whom shall we go to
whom shall we go say will you leave the
church now because of all these scandals
will you leave this church or that
church to whom shall we go to whom shall
we go there's no this is if if this is
the truth and we have to follow this we
have to look toward Jesus you know and
this actually another reading this week
was from Ephesians and it was the
reading now you know these days in some
of the more liberal Catholic liturgies
they omit the part about wives
submitting to their husbands and they
only include the part about husbands
loving their wives the the reading says
wives submit to your husband's husbands
love your wives and you'll see in
brackets on the first part now they'll
say you don't have to read this know you
don't know that's a little it might be a
little touchy yeah it's a little touchy
these are hard sayings but it you know
the church is the Bride of Christ Christ
is the bridegroom and an issue here if
Francis wants to talk about clericalism
is that people are not looking to their
to their husband which is Christ they
certainly need to do that what can you
do in very practical terms you can vote
with your wallet
if you're a Catholic don't give to
bishops collections the bishops appeal
Catholic Relief Services organizations
that are tied to the u.s. Council of caf
Bishop's I once had a priest say to me
that he liked my book reasons to vote
for Democrats a comprehensive guide
completely blank he said he was
considering one called
reasons to listen to the u.s. Council of
Catholic Bishops so that's one ways you
can vote with your wallet and I
recommend you do the question that
everyone's asking is should Francis
resign the top diplomat Vatican's
diplomat to the United States is calling
on him to resign we need to find out if
his testimony is true it's been
corroborated by other people by other
high-ranking Vatican officials who have
said quote vegan oh is telling the truth
that's all I'm going to say that seems
true there is some precedence here where
Francis said Pope Francis said in May
that bishops should retire they
shouldn't die in office including the
Pope this was kind of a shock it seemed
to that he might he might give up the
pontificate willingly Pope Benedict did
that before him he resigned the papacy
under what circumstances were not sure
but he did retire and so using Francis's
own logic perhaps he should listen to
his own words if it comes to that if
these allegations are true if Francis
really believes that the Pope can retire
and should retire if he supports
transparency if he supports an end to
clericalism then this this will be very
important I know I really wanted to go
through this because I know to two
Outsiders and even to Catholics the
details of the Catholic Church and the
Vatican and Catholic hierarchy are a
little murky and a little strange and
seem like they're out of you know the
7th century or something because often
they are but the this event is
earth-shattering
I mean this is if I weren't told by
Scripture that the church will exist
until the end of the world I would I
would be raising an eyebrow right now
but the church will endure until the end
of the world and if the church is the
church the church will endure until the
end of the world and we're going through
a very very rocky period don't let
anybody tell you that this is some minor
question the Pope could resign over this
and we'll see if that happens ok
speaking of spiritual wickedness in high
places
let's talk about corruption in
bureaucracies I spoke with Eric Eggers a
terrific guy and the author of fraud had
the left plans to steal the next
election where he goes oh through all of
the history of voter fraud and now we're
told all the time by the left there's no
such thing as voter fraud it's not real
bla bla bla bla bla he lays it out this
is an excellent book and here is what
Eric has to say about how the left is
gonna try to steal the midterms in 2020
Eric thank you so much for being here
great Michael I'm glad to be here I
loved this book I highly recommend that
everybody reads it before Election Day
and the midterms and 2020 and every
other election because you know the
Democrats like to vote early and vote
often and what's shocking to me about
this whole situation we're in is the
Democrats say there is no election fraud
it never happens we never try to steal
elections and if you pass any laws to
stop us we're gonna murder you we're
gonna go in and kill you guys
how extensive is this problem in reality
well I think all you have to do is take
a look at the reaction anyone guess
anytime they suggest that voter fraud
might be a problem as you noted you know
I do steer a little clear of accusing
anyone of outright murder in the book
although that was that was an editorial
decision you know at the end but at the
end of the day know the stakes are very
serious I mean it's it's not actual
murder but it might as well be a
professional murder because if you do do
anything that might try to make
elections more secure at the least
you're gonna be called a racist and at
the worst you'll be subject to never any
lawsuits by Soros and DNC funded Hydra
so it's an incredibly pervasive problem
so like how widespread is it
well how vigorous is the protestation
and the effort to stop anyone from
trying to do it look at what happened to
Ohio recently you're still having a
contested election there and imagine
what would happen if the state of Ohio
had been unsuccessful in its efforts to
fight Soros funded efforts to do two
things right make elections more secure
by removing illegal voters from the
voting rolls and requiring people to
show a voter ID both those things are
common sense if they had to fight for as
many people every turn that's right and
you know I want to go back to the racism
accusation because this is what we hear
we hear if you want to have voter ID
laws you want people to show the same
idea that they need to get a pack of
cigarettes when they go vote that that's
racist somehow it dis franchises black
voters or something but
you cite specific instances in the book
did show that this is not true that
these laws are not unpopular with
minority voters and that it doesn't
suppress the minority vote yet for
whatever reason it's not considered
racist to suggest that there's entire
classes of people that are incapable of
doing things that other classes of
people are doing you know Michael if you
wanted to buy an alcoholic beverage if
you want to get on an airplane if you
wanted to go to the Democratic National
Convention and 26 you didn't needed you
needed a driver's license I guess
they're racist so no I mean in state of
Alabama they passed the voter ID law
before the recent election when Roy
Moore was on the ballot they saw an
increase in minority turnout the state
of Ohio instead of Georgia I've seen
similar things so the reality is there
is no evidence to suggest that requiring
an ID
in any way suppresses or oppresses
menorah turnout the Washington Post did
their best to suggest that that was the
case but they were actually rebuked very
quickly after they published a study by
academics from Ivy League institutions
though there is no evidence to support
it and in fact we've seen the opposite
out that's right I think in the New York
Times actually even admitted they said
you know this surge in minority voting
in Alabama does throw a wrench in our
narrative basically and it's so absurd
it's basically saying it's it's always
white liberals and they're saying oh no
no we black people can't get IDs we
can't they can't we can't expect them to
do that
as though it's like another species of
people black people are they're smart
they're just as smart as you are they
can go down and get their own ID and go
you know buy a pack of cigarettes or a
drink or vote or god forbid go to the
Democrat National Convention and also
the these voter ID laws are not
unpopular with minority voters isn't
that right no that's right the majority
of people don't think that there's
anything wrong with requiring that they
should have to show an ID yeah I think
this myth of voter ID being oppressive
it's like the equivalent of you know
kind of claiming the wrong height on
your driver's license like I wish I was
six feet tall but there's just no
evidence that supported that's right so
this it's exactly the same case with
with anybody to claim that voter ID laws
are unpopular or oppressive so the
Democrats deny that voter fraud happens
even though we've uncovered these these
instances there was that precinct
several precincts I think in
Philadelphia in 2012
that recorded zero votes for Mitt Romney
you've got other pretty dodgy instances
of thousands of absentee ballots being
written in the same hand showing up
last-minute in races that are decided by
a few hundred votes possibly so the
people who deny that voter fraud happens
now what did they say about all the past
examples because you you take us in the
book through this great journey of all
of the wonderful methods and instances
of voter fraud going back to America's
earliest days
thank you it's like the Oregon Trail of
voters pardon got the blurb I'm gonna
tribute to you from my website no I
think that there's a key thing you're
touching on right and that's this that
the left which is the Brennan Center and
other Thoros funded groups they define
voter fraud in very specific terms and
they define it in what's called no an
under inclusive way and so they define
it only as an act of intentional
impersonation on behalf of an illegal
voter right who's impersonating a legal
voter and there's evidence to say that
that's actually quite easy to do but but
the two instances that you just
referenced the thanks to the eighteen
precincts in Philadelphia in which Mitt
Romney received zero votes in the 2012
election which is a statistical anomaly
it's impossible for that to happen even
just through sheer error or the hundreds
of ballots that had the same signatures
actually hundreds of ballot request
forms in which the supervisor of
elections in South Florida was basically
powerless and had to spend the ballots
out for them wow those are both actually
those are actually both things that are
legal and so they don't qualify or
classify as voter fraud and and I think
that really touches on an important
point either what the Left considers to
be voter fraud is that very narrow
definition that I shared but what I
think you or I or the majority of people
that are watching this podcast or even
just common sense Americans they would
define voter fraud as anything that
Rob's the true weight of an honest
American vote and the the real crime of
it is not and I try to lay this out in
the book is that a vast majority those
things are legal and so that's why these
two sides were to speak past each other
the Left says Oh voter fraud is very
rare because they defined it so narrowly
and the right would say well voter fraud
is actually quite pervasive and and
they're right because things that most
people would consider to be a voter
fraud does happen I mean I we talk about
this in the book as well in a GI the
Government Accountability Institute or
whom I work we commissioned a study as
part of the process of this book and we
said all right let's take a look at
actual ballots cast in the 2016 election
we compiled all the publicly available
voter rolls we could get we have 2,100
instances of double voting in the state
of Florida alone I mean somebody kept
you know 2,100 people cast the ballot in
the state of Florida where I live and
then cast the second ballot somewhere
else so that's illegal but the left
wouldn't consider that to be voter fraud
there's nearly three million people by
the way that are registered to vote in
more than one state in this country up
to 24 million voter registrations are
highly inaccurate or completely wrong
Supreme Court cited those stats recently
so we've got major problems in the
system right there's a million illegal
immigrants to have driver's license in
California there's 248 counties in this
country with more registered voters than
citizen to legal voting age so it's not
a question of is the system flawed the
left just tries to couch and get very
cute in terms of well does that mean is
it actual this impersonation and most
people say listen where there's
opportunities for fraud or where the
errors occur and we know that there's
errors all over of course and you see I
mean there are so many instances now
especially these motor voter laws where
you can illegally register to vote and
then legally vote right you're it's you
should have never have been registered
to vote in the first place but once
you're registered then then you're
registered then you can show up to the
polls and vote or you can do it by
absentee or whatever it's so you know
the left wants to pretend that we've got
that we're talking about when people
break into an election place and go and
stand in line there's so many other ways
to do it you talk about 20 20 200 votes
in Florida that could have thrown the
2000 presidential election multiple
times several times over and and a lot
of times by the way people might not
know that they're ineligible to vote you
talked about this in the book yeah it's
a key point and this is another area
where I think the left says one thing
and it's sort of beggars belief like
yeah they're right that there aren't
millions of illegal immigrants like
getting a bat signal somewhere from
George Soros and running to the poll the
Soros scandal true like I'm willing to
admit that right but but it's absolutely
true is that the vulnerability
that the left fights to protect like
every time they fight against the voter
ID law for every time they fight to try
to keep the voter rolls from having
illegal voters removed they actually end
up exploiting the population that they
would claim to be wanting to protect it
was actually leftist immigration
attorneys that turned me on to this as
part of the research for the book and I
talked about several examples in the
book of people that are you know these
are non-citizens even in some instances
work for polling places but they don't
know that they're not supposed to be
voting and the law prevents the DMV
officials who is the only safeguard
between the non citizen and the voter
rolls that not the DMV officials not
allowed to give any guidance and say
well are you a citizen are you not a
citizen
you've got people whose command of
English isn't terrific their command of
civics probably could use a bit of
scrubbing and so you get these people
that they get up on the roll and then
you've got and then so now they're a
registered voter whether or not whether
it should be voting or not and they
shouldn't be
and that's actually a crime for them to
be a registered voter and then them
registering to vote actually precludes
them from ever becoming a naturalized
citizen and in some cases may cause them
to face deportation but then what's on
the voter rolls now they're a target for
these groups of politically motivated
tourists funded people they're called
bullet arrows in South Florida or
politically rose and Texas and there's
people that they get told that they
should sell their vote and they say well
I guess this is how it's done because in
some cases they may come from countries
in which that is the way it's done and
and so absolutely you've got numerous
examples of non-citizens they didn't
realize they were violating the law and
now we're caught up as the victims of an
incredibly vulnerable electoral system
that's right and to say nothing of
another aspect that's built into this
which is the census you know
representation in Congress is based on
the population of the state not the
legal population of the state so already
illegal aliens in the country or skewing
the American electorate in the American
vote just just by their virtue of being
counted in the US Census yeah believe
it's five electoral votes are considered
to be given to non-citizens in
California which basically makes
non-citizens
the equivalent of at least fourteen
states from an electoral math standpoint
and you know the tail on this there's
two things like one you're absolutely
right and the second piece of it is is
that as we know
Tom Perez in the head of the Democratic
National Committee their whole goal is
to expand non citizen voting run and
that's the who could tell metell on this
was when there was all this discussion
about the census and whether or not we
should include this question of
non-citizen chip on the census what
happened you saw Tom Perez invoke voter
intimidation and violating the Voting
Rights Act but what is inquiring about
somebody's citizenship have to do with
violating the Voting Rights Act and it's
because and we see this in San Francisco
where illegal immigrants are now able to
cast ballots in local and municipal
elections Tom prezi used to work for a
group that is also on the tail end of
there was funding called Casa de
Maryland like an acorn and the Raza type
group in the state of Maryland and their
big push was to advocate for non citizen
voting right Tom Perez his hometown of
Takoma Park Maryland has been allowing
voting right since 1992 for non-citizens
so it's sort of insane that was actually
one of the things I was most floored by
when I wrote the book it was like wow I
I didn't realize non-citizens were able
to legally cast ballots in this country
I think luckily they're not able to cast
ballots in federal elections but for the
first time Democrats and you know
Democrats believe that illegal
immigrants who pay taxes should be able
to vote in election right a majority of
Democrats 53% of self-described liberal
54 percent of Democrats believe illegal
aliens who pay taxes should be able to
vote so this is clearly the future and
yeah it's only a matter of time before
we start to see an argument about well
why can't non fittin to vote in federal
elections that's right it's a shocking
number and of course you know the minute
that anybody who happens to be here gets
to vote then the whole idea of a nation
disappears which is sources goal and you
know I I think sometimes people even on
the right but certainly people on the
left they think that we're boogie
Manning George Soros a little bit this
sort of evil wicked guy coincidentally I
actually when I was as a young actor in
New York I was hired to be a sommelier
at George Soros's wedding I kid you not
so I actually got to see these speeches
firsthand and and it was really pretty
nefarious left-wing stuff got to see I
got to see the man I was several feet
away from him and so I have heard from
from the guy's own mouth I've heard the
goals of the open society foundation I
can't if they ever found out I was a
Republican there I would have
literally been torn and feathered you
know or maybe ritually so you're a good
actor right yeah it's true I guess I was
wearing my pink hat you know and looking
real cool I already have my Matt out
glasses on and so I do want to ask just
in the last few minutes here about the
soros of it all where he's got his
tentacles and what we have to look out
for it before the next election right
and it's a great question Michael so one
of the things that people need to
realize is the Soros funded groups do
two things right they fight against any
effort to increase election security so
the state of Ohio which I mentioned
previously they had to fight against you
know mark Elias who was the Clinton
campaign attorney ahead of 2016 filed a
lawsuit to block Ohio's implementation
of their voter ID law well he was filing
that on behalf of he was actually paid
by George Soros file that lawsuit the
state of Ohio also has had you fight
against its efforts as a noted to remove
illegal voters from their voting rolls
well Soros was behind that as well
stores money so this is what to do so
they fund organizations to fight against
any effort to increase election security
at the same time he then funds groups
like La Raza and acorn who then go out
and roust up as many voters as possible
and funnel these voters through the gaps
that the other organizations fight to
make sure still exists regardless of
whether these voters are illegal or not
right I mean why have a corn in La Raza
actually changed their name because of
how chronically affiliated they were
with voter registration fraud or voter
from that one of the groups one of the
groups on behalf of mark Elias who was
he was working for this Republic
Ohio organizing collaborative they
actually had an employee arrested and
sentenced to jail for registering dead
people to vote so it just speaks to sort
of the the Nexus of the organizations in
the effort and yeah so I think it's
actually quite insidious and it's kind
of intelligent if you weren't concerned
about the ramifications for the crime
right well you know President Trump has
made inroads and a lot of formerly
democratic demographics you know
blue-collar workers and he's increased
to support among the black vote and he's
done very well maybe we can also get
some of the dead vote too you know
that's been a solid Democrat lock for
decades but who knows I mean the miracle
seemed to be happening so well just to
give you an idea of why the voter rolls
like whether they had people on the
roles or felons or people that no longer
live in that state and I know if you go
but just to give you a quick example of
how easy those vulnerabilities and
errors can be exploited by motivated
political groups the city of New York
then into the state of New York actually
sent in undercover agent into New York
City elections because they wanted to
see all right we know there's problems
here and so they said we want to see how
easily the problems are manipulated so
they send in undercover agents to vote
on behalf of felons on behalf of people
that are dead or behalf of people that
no longer lived in the state and they
tried to cast a total of 63 ballot
sixty-one of those sixty three attempts
were successful while and and one of the
only and this includes like a 26 year
old undercover agent voting on behalf of
somebody that's nearly 80 years old
right so it's not like there's not real
matchy-matchy but one of the only people
that was stopped was trying to vote on
behalf of a felon who shouldn't have
been on the voter roll and the only
reason they couldn't vote is because the
felons mother was actually working to
Poli oh gosh right unbelievable so I
mean I think that's bestowed so they
keep the air is in place and then the
errors are incredibly easily exploitable
and that's basically the recipe for how
it happened well people have to read the
book because it gives a lot of hope in
that the the law is on our side the
history is on our side the public
opinion is on our side and hope it looks
like we can protect the integrity of our
elections a lot better in the future but
you got to know where the problem is so
you got to read the book Eric I will let
you go thank you so much for being here
great thanks Michael it's great to be
here Eric Eggers very terrifying I
highly recommend you read fraud it reads
very quickly it's really easily written
you know it's not like you're gonna be
laboring over it all the time it just
lays out the case it lays out the facts
really well you should read it before
the midterms fraud I gotta say goodbye
to Facebook in YouTube we have a lot
more to get to and I want to talk about
John McCain the first presidential
candidate I ever voted for at age 18 but
if you're on Daley wire thank you very
much you helped keep the lights on if
you're on Facebook and YouTube go to
daily wire what are you doing you're
about to be censored anyway I'm
sure they're tracking all your data
you're gonna have like a team of thugs
from one of the big tech companies come
and invade your house get off there go
to daily wire it's a hundred bucks for
an annual membership it's ten bucks a
month you get me you get the intro
claiming sure you get the Ben Shapiro
show you get to ask questions in the
conversation that's coming up Thursday
you have to ask questions no I'm sorry
the conversations coming up later you
have questions the mailbag you get a lot
of stuff is what I'm saying you get a
lot of stuff you get this you get the
leftist tears tumblr perhaps we should
have a clerical Edition of this perhaps
we should have a Bishop's version a
Bishop's of vintage for all those bad
left-wing bishops who are implicated and
abuse maybe we should we should we will
have a lot of different vintages for you
make sure you get your leftist tiers
tumblr because also we're not going to
let them steal the elections you'll need
this otherwise she'll drown go to daily
we're calm we'll be back to talk about
John McCain and Alexandria Ocasio Cortes
[Music]
[Music]
we're gonna find out one day that
Alexandria Oh Cassio Cortez is actually
constructed by Republican strategists to
give us something to talk about I think
it was something to make fun of to give
us so you know my gosh she's got another
one which is really great I'm gonna
explain to her why her latest statement
also proves she's not the expert she
made one of the stupidest statements
she's ever made before that let's talk
about John McCain John McCain died he he
you know American war hero he was shot
down over Vietnam he served his country
he was held as a prisoner of war for
years and years he refused early release
he didn't want to jump the line he could
have jumped the line because his father
was a very important Admiral and he
didn't do that that alone is worthy of
admiration even though people have
political disagreements with John McCain
conservatives do certainly but
regardless that that alone is worthy of
admiration we shouldn't lose sight of
that
the thing I want to talk about really
John McCain doesn't need us to talk
about him he's lived a very
consequential life in American politics
plaudits are flying in he's you know his
service speaks for itself
you know what what I do want to talk
about is the mainstream media because
the mainstream media or they are loving
John McCain right now they article after
article attacking people for not saying
enough about John McCain and I am
reminded of how the mainstream media
treated John McCain in 2008 do you
remember this because I'm old enough to
remember when John McCain was racist he
was old he's senile he's stupid he's an
adulterer he this was with the
mainstream media said this is what the
left said in 2008 now all of a sudden
he's Saint John he's he's you know the
greatest American who's ever lived and
it's so awful all those unctuous
mainstream media vultures who
politicized this guy's death what should
be said about John McCain is he has a
distinguished record of service to the
country he was a prisoner of war he
chose to remain which was very
courageous loved his country his record
speaks for itself they just have to
politicize everything too
attack Donald Trump or do attack John
McCain when he posed a threat to them
here is here's just an investigation a
sort of special about John McCain that
ran in 2008 when he was running for the
president here's how CNN treated John
McCain then McCain wrote in his memoir
it began dating Cindy after he separated
from his wife Carol
in fact his own divorce filings shows
they dated for nine months while he was
still living with Carol and records show
he applied for a marriage license in
Arizona before his divorce was final the
chronology that has presented publicly
doesn't necessarily match the chronology
of the documents that you had applied
for a marriage license in Arizona at a
time when your divorce wasn't final yet
dun dun dun the music that McCain
revealed like this guy is the worst
person who ever lived because he cheated
on his wife mind you this is the cable
news network
that defended Bill Clinton vigorously
during all of his sex scandals
vigorously defended him but now
bum-bum-bum we're gonna get John McCain
revealed they were awful to this guy
they savaged him Barack Obama aired a
commercial that said McCain was too old
to know how to use email and the the
network's ran with this story is too old
he's senile he's racist he's an
adulterer he picked Sarah Palin who's an
idiot mind you Sarah Palin much more
qualified to be president than Barack
Obama much much more qualified to be
President all of these things they they
ruined this guy's life and reputation
when he posed a threat to them and then
when he stopped posing a threat and when
it was convenient politically for them
to embrace him that's when they embraced
him it's really disgusting I can't even
I can't even think about it you know
voxcom
which is not the most honest media site
out there at least they were honest
about this they were honest about their
their disdain for John McCain they said
John McCain he he created Trump
basically because he chose Sarah Palin
as a running mate they say that because
of that he advocated populism which
allowed Trump to come in at least Fox
was honest though because they don't
they don't like John McCain they don't
like Republicans to them you know if
John McCain were still alive and running
for president again they'd do the same
thing they'd say he's a racist and
sexist and all that kind of stuff
and this is where I'd like to make an
observation about the hysteria around
Trump's response to McCain's death at
least Trump was being sort of consistent
here to John McCain sent out this tweet
and his tweet said quote my deepest
sympathies in respect go out to the
family of Senator John McCain our hearts
and prayers are with you and he's being
pilloried because he didn't give a nice
eulogy to John McCain or a panegyric or
something if Donald Trump ran basically
against John McCain he ran a John McCain
opposed the Trump agenda Donald Trump
said mean nasty things about John McCain
he said he wasn't a war hero he just you
know he's been running against him John
McCain was the the vote that killed the
Obamacare repeal they've got a lot of
bad blood between the two of them what
was Donald Trump supposed to say I
actually was predicting weeks ago I said
what are the odds that we get through
the death of John McCain without a
horrific ly offensive statement from
Donald Trump what are the odds and then
we did we made it through he said on my
respect and condolences to the family
perhaps this is just an aspect of me
having low expectations what more do you
want what more could we have asked for
what if he said what if he came out and
said John McCain is a great hero and he
was a wonderful man and I love John
McCain then what would the press be
saying about him he's a liar he's a
hypocrite how dare he talk about John
McCain you're not fit to shine John
McCain's shoes they anything he said
they'd be ripping apart I thought as far
as the potential responses that we could
have gotten from President Trump this
was pretty good Ben you didn't say
anything mean about him he didn't rehash
old battles he just said my respect and
condolences go out to the family that's
fine chalk it up as a win
how should conservatives feel we're
running out of time but we should talk
about this how should conservatives feel
we didn't always agree with John McCain
on very many important issues we
disagreed intensely with John McCain he
he passed mccain feingold which was that
campaign finance legislation that was
then overturned by the Supreme Court
because it was a violation of free
speech he was always a maverick as he
was styled in the media he wasn't a
conservative he wouldn't have really
called himself a hard-line conservative
he would cross the aisle frequently
he touted his relationships with
Democrats in the Senate he I believe he
wanted to choose Joe Lieberman to be his
running mate in 2008 so sure
conservatives don't agree with John
McCain politically a lot of the time
still the guy died the guy just died
he served his country his war service
alone should be enough to say he was a
man who loved his country I didn't see
eye to eye to it with him but he loved
his country serve this country and rest
in peace
that's what conservatives should say we
can relitigate certain policy
differences later on especially as they
become more important again these things
always crop up but you know salute John
McCain I realized technically he's not
the first president I voted for because
when I was 6 years old my mother let me
go into the booth with her I convinced
her to vote for Dole and she let me pull
the lever so maybe I maybe I committed
election fraud maybe I'm gonna be an
Eric agar his next book but John McCain
is the first guy I voted for when I
turned 18 and I got to you know I got to
actually do it myself and pull the lever
so rest easy Senator McCain and before
we go I guess we've just got a couple
more minutes now Alexandria Ocasio
Cortes she's back she's back the gift
that keeps on giving
Ocasio tweeted out this quote hashtag
abolish ice means not having an agency
that incarcerates children and sexually
assaults women with impunity it does not
mean abolish deportation also I have no
problem saying white supremacy has no
place in this country
it's the GOP that struggles to say that
GOP founded to free the slaves founded
to free the slaves from the Democrats
how many just a question for all the
Republicans watching how many of you
struggle to say that white supremacy is
bad any zero zero people say that okay
that's what I thought but I would I
would like to make this point clear for
Ocasio Cortes I know she watches this
show I know she do she watches it every
day religiously she is caught here
because ice just deported an actual Nazi
from the country Immigration and Customs
Enforcement went in and deported a Nazi
war criminal back to Germany so yes like
isn't some deportations are good aren't
Ocasio and she's saying no abolish ice
does not mean abolish deportation so I'm
gonna lay this out free ice stands for
Immigration and Customs Enforcement
immigration enforcement means deporting
people who have immigrated illegally who
are in the country illegally therefore
and see if you can stay with me
abolishing immigration enforcement means
abolishing the mechanism of immigration
enforcement which is deportations QED
qe that's the that's alright is that
fair I don't I feel like I'm a crazy
person now because you've got a major
store of the Democrat Party saying that
that's not what it means that's clearly
what it means this is a big loser issue
she knows that she's saying these
slogans because she doesn't know
anything because she's not the expert to
put it mildly and so they're saying
abolish eyes only a quarter of Democrats
want to abolish immigration enforcement
and the only reason they want to do that
is because they don't know they know
even less than Ocasio does so she's got
to walk this back but let's just be very
clear I don't want to let her off the
hook abolishing ice means abolishing
deportations if you don't want to
abolish deportations then you don't want
to abolish ice if you do want to abolish
ice you want to abolish deportations she
should give an answer on this that we
should hold her feet to the fire I don't
know why she keeps going in public I
don't know why she keeps going on
television the race is hers just shut up
and you'll win the race the more the
only risk you have of not winning this
race somehow is when you open your mouth
but we should get an answer from her on
that I hope she keeps opening her mouth
because she's just a joy what a delight
is why I wake up in the morning anything
Oh what did what did that little
socialist lady say today guru guru okay
that's our show
tune in we got a lot of good stuff to
talk about this week we will get to more
of it in the meantime I'm Michael
Knowles this is the Michael Noel's show
see you tomorrow
the Michael Nolt show is produced by
seniya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer
Mathis Glover and our technical producer
is Austin Stevens edited by Jim nickel
audio is mixed by mic core Amina hair
and makeup is by Jessa alvera the
Michael Noel's show is a daily wire for
word publishing production copyright for
word publishing 2018
you
you